they are expecting another big crowd at
the las vegas ballpark the aviators are
hosting salt lake and there will be over
a thousand special guests in the stadium
they're going to be honored tonight yes
it is metro police night at the ballpark
john treach looking like a relief
pitcher as he is holding a baseball and
giving us a live report from the
ballpark
throwing strikes all night long brian
appreciate you i tell you what it is a
beautiful night for baseball and as you
can see fans are already starting to
make their way to the berm and right
field and it's going to be close to
another sellout which is amazing for
minor league baseball on a wednesday in
may so it's certainly a wonderful
opportunity to come in and support a
good cause i'm joined right now by
pamela puppel from the las vegas metro
police department foundation and you're
trying to raise money for some of your
organizations here how big an event is
this for your for your group this is an
amazing event to have a thousand police
officers and staff and their families
here and to show support for public
safety this is wonderful for us and it's
an opportunity to interact in a
non-crime situation correct it's great
for positive community engagement
opportunity here where people can just
go and talk to a police officer we have
the deputy chief throwing out the first
pitch tonight so it's great to see
officers that aren't really on the beat
right now
and i understand that the deputy chief
has a pretty good arm she's ready she is
ready she said she was on ice all night
well thank you so much for your time and
i talked to the deputy chief and i asked
i was like do you think you're going to
throw a strike and she kind of gave me a
glare i left it at that so reporting
live from the ballpark john treats live
local now